بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الحمد لله رب العالمين والصلاه والسلام
على نبينا محمد وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين
[موسيقى]
صاحب السمو الملكي
الاخ العزيز الامير محمد بن سلمان بن عبد
العزيز ال سعود ولي العهد رئيس مجلس
الوزراء بالمملكه العربيه السعوديه في
الشقيقه اصحاب الجلاله والفخامه والسمو
معالي السيد احمد ابو الغير الامين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه
اصحاب المعالي والسعاده السيدات والساده
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله وبركاته
يطيب لي ممثلا عن حضره صاحب السمو
الشيخ نواف الاحمد الجابر الصباح امير
دوله الكويت حفظه الله ورعاه ان انقل لكم
جميعا تحياتي سموه وتمنياته لكم بالتوفيق
والسداد في كل ما فيه خير خير
امتنا العربيه وخدمه قضاياها العادله
كما يطيب لي ان اتقدم بالتهنئه الى قياده
المملكه العربيه السعوديه الشقيقه على
رئاستها لاعمال هذه القمه في دورتها
الثانيه والثلاثين
معربين عن ثقتنا بانما تحظى به من خبره
وحكمه سيكلل اعمالنا بالنجاح والتوفيق
شاكرين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
الشقيقه قياده وحكومه وشعبا على ما احطنا
به من كرم ضيافه وما شاهدناه من اعداد
مميزا لهذا اللقاء الهام كما اشكر اخي
العزيز فخامه الرئيس عبد المجيد تبون رئيس
الجمهوريه الجزائريه الديمقراطيه الشعبيه
الشقيقه على ما بدله من جهود خلال رئاسته
لاعمال قمتنا السابقه ولا يفوتنا الاشاره
بجهود معاني امين العام
لجامعه الدول العربيه السيد احمد ابو
الغيظ وجهاز الامانه العامه لجامعه الدول
العربيه على اعداد لقائنا ومتابعته
الحضور الكرام اننا نشعر بالتفاؤل لبوادر
الانفراجات الحاصله في المنطقه ومنها
البيان المشترك بين كل من المملكه العربيه
السعيد الشقيقه والجمهوريه الاسلاميه
الايرانيه الصديقه برعايه جمهوريه الصين
الشعبيه الصديقه
مؤكدين ان هذه التفاهمات ستنعكس ايجابا
على استقرار المنطقه وازدهارها وتحقيق
تطلعات شعوبها الا ان التفاؤل يمتزج
بالقلق احياء الاستمرار بعض التحيات بعض
التحديات التي يواجهها وطننا العربي اذ
ياتي اجتماعنا اليوم في ظل تطورات متسارعه
تحيط بدولنا العربيه والتي تنعكس بلا شك
على امن منطقتنا واستقرارها كما ان
استمرار بعض الاضطرابات في العالم ومنها
يحدث في اوكرانيا له تبعات خطيره على
الامن والسلم الدوليين الامر الذي يحتم
علينا وضع التصورات والاليات المناسبه
للتعامل مع هذه التطورات والتحديات
وفيما يتعلق بشان السوري
فان دوله الكويت تجدد تاييدها لقرار مجلس
جامعه الدول العربيه رقم ثمانيه تسعه واحد
اربعه
وترحيبها كذلك بالبيان الصادر في اعقاب
اجتماع جده والبيان الصادر عن اجتماع عمان
وكلنا امل في ان تكون عوده سوريا الى بيت
العرب منطلقا بانتهاء الازمه ومعاناه
الشعب السوري الشقيق وفي هذا الشان
تؤكد دوله الكويت موقفها المبدئي الثابت
الداعي الى الحفاظ على وحده وسياده سوريا
وسلامه اراضيها ورفض اي تدخل في شؤونها
الداخليه
وموقفنا المستمر منذ بدايه الاحداث بتقديم
الدعم الانساني لكافه اطياف الشعب السوري
متطلعين في هذا الصدد الى التزام الحكومه
السوريه بما تضمنه بيانا بيانا جده وعمان
وقرار مجلس الامن رقم اثنين اثنين خمسه
اربعه وبما يظن عوده سوريا لممارسه دورها
الطبيعي المؤثر في محيطها العربي
والاقليمي والدولي
الحضور الكرام ستبقى القضيه الفلسطينيه
على راس الاولويات والتحديات التي تواجه
امتنا العربيه ونود التاكيد هنا على موقف
دوله الكويت الثابت الداعم لحقوق الشعب
الفلسطيني الشقيق في مواجهه الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي وعدوانه وجرائمه التي تمس
الوضع التاريخي لمدينه القدس كما ندعو
المجتمع الدولي الى القيام بدوره لاعاده
احياء عمليه السلام وصولا الى حل عادل
شاملا وفق ما نصه عليه قرارات الشرعيه
الدوليه ومبادره السلام العربيه
وبما يضمن حق الشعب الفلسطيني الشقيق في
اقامه دولته المستقله على ارضه وعاصمتها
القدس الشرقيه وختاما فان امام دولنا
العربي المسؤوليات وتحديات جسام تتطلب منا
جميعا بدل المزيد من الجهود وتنسيق
المواقف لضمان مستقبل امن مستقر في كافه
ربوع وطننا العربي متمنيا لاعمال هذه
القمه كل التوفيق والسداد والسلام عليكم
ورحمه الله وبركاته
[تصفيق]
لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب
الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس
التنبيهات